[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an american supernatural
drama television series called manifest
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the stone family is at an airport in
jamaica waiting for their flight back
home to new york the airline announces
that because of a booking overload some
passengers will have to transfer to
flight 828 that will take off a while
later a police detective michaela her
brother ben and his leukemic son cow
decide to take flight 828 while the rest
of the family fly home early in the
following scene the trio are already in
flight 828 and are waiting to land
suddenly a storm appears out of nowhere
making the plane go through aggressive
turbulence the lights go off and
emergency lights are turned on making
everyone panic a minute later everything
goes back to normal and they continue
their way to the jfk airport however the
pilot is asked to make a descent to
another airport the operator on the
other end sounds nervous upon hearing
the name of flight 828 the pilots are
told that there will be military and
medical personnel waiting for them when
they touch down still confused they land
the plane the director of the nsa vance
is the main investigator on the scene he
informs the confused passengers that
they flew from jamaica on april 7 2013
but the current date is november 4th
2018. everyone on the flight has been
missing and presumed dead for the past
five and a half years then we are taken
back to the day they were at the airport
the daughter michaela is a detective in
the new york police department she looks
at her family and thinks about how
stressed they are behind their happy
faces her brother ben and his wife grace
have been married for 15 years and are
still in love they have a pair of twins
cal and olive cal was born with leukemia
and has been given six months to live
and olive has a terrible name ben and
grace are always worried about their son
helplessly trying to find a way to save
him then there is michaela's mother who
is asking her to take a step forward in
life and get married michaela was
recently proposed to by her long-term
boyfriend jared she is taking time to
give him a reply because she is still
recovering from the trauma of something
that happened recently back in the
present the passengers think this is
some kind of sick joke but they soon
realize vance is being dead serious upon
further investigation it is clear that
the passengers haven't aged a single day
since the departure the people from nsa
expect an answer from the passengers but
they are as clueless as everyone else
they are kept in a camp for the rest of
the night and interrogated individually
all their answers are the same they do
not know what happened 36 hours later
the news makes it to the world and
creates a sensation the families of the
passengers run to the airport to be
reunited with their loved ones who they
thought died long ago it is a crazy
experience for both the passengers and
their families ben reunites with his
daughter who is now a teenager they grow
up so fast cal is shocked to see that
his twin is now double his height grace
on the other hand could not be happier
to have them back however ben and
michaela find out that their mother
passed away two years ago they have a
hard time processing the information so
they decide to go home and rest first
while the rest of the world loses their
mind the family settles into their
changed home simultaneously scientists
start examining the airplane but find
nothing out of the ordinary michaela is
worried because her fiance jared didn't
come to meet her at the airport she goes
to her workplace to meet him and is
greeted by a senior detective he
welcomes her back to the job even though
she has been mia for five years other
than the return of flight 828 the news
about two girls being abducted from
their backyard has also made television
jared is the lead detective on the case
and is very busy upon meeting him
michaela finds out that it is not the
only reason he didn't come to meet her
it turns out he married her best friend
lourdes last year michaela is shocked
because lords is a terrible name and
because to her it has only been two days
since she and jared were engaged the
first thing ben does upon returning home
is take cal to the doctor over the years
researchers have found a way to treat
his leukemia which means he can live
more than six months the couple can
almost not believe the news meanwhile
michaela is returning home on a bus when
she hears a voice asking the driver to
slow down the voice is so strong that
she yells at the driver and saves a
kid's life right before the bus is about
to hit him then we are introduced to a
medical researcher named savi she was
also on flight 828 and is returning to
her workplace after five years the
research she submitted right before her
disappearance has been in practice for
the past two years and has cured cancer
her co-workers throw her a surprise
party welcoming her back the next
morning michaela goes on a run and comes
across two dogs barking at her from
inside a gate she hears the calling in
her head for the second time this time
the voice asks her to let them free she
thinks about it for a second before
continuing to jog hours pass and it gets
dark but the voice doesn't go away at
midnight michaela goes to the dogs again
and is joined by ben a while later it
turns out he also heard the same calling
that she did they break open the door
and let the dogs free but decide to not
tell anyone about the callings the
entire world's eyes are upon them so if
they say something strange people might
want to perform experiments on them the
following day the police find security
footage of the incident jared keeps it
on the down low to keep michaela out of
trouble he asks her why she let the dogs
free but even she doesn't have an answer
to that they find the dogs and go to the
owner to apologize in the meantime ben
tries to mend his relationship with
olive going to her football games and
catching up with her life they decide to
take it slow because after carl and
ben's disappearance olive had to go to
therapy for many years as soon as
michaela gets closer to the dogs she
again hears the voice asking to set them
free jared talks to the dog's owner
explaining the situation to him but
michaela cannot focus because of the
voice she suddenly breaks open the door
to a room out of pure instinct inside
are the two girls who were kidnapped a
few days ago the voice had been asking
her to set the girls free not the dogs
jared is shocked but he doesn't have
time to comprehend what happened because
he has to arrest the kidnapper the
police force believes michaela is ready
to continue her job since she was able
to solve the case right after returning
they allow her to come to work but put
her on desk duty for a few days
somewhere else ben and the family are
playing a board game together grace gets
a text from her boyfriend saying that he
misses her she was in a relationship
with a man before ben's return but
doesn't have the guts to tell him yet at
the same time some passengers on the
flight get a slight headache and
something in their hearts tells them to
go to the airport instantly when they
arrive they are shocked to see each
other knowing that all of them had the
same urge suddenly the airplane explodes
into pieces without anything triggering
it when the nsa finds out that 20
passengers were present at the scene
they are brought in for interrogation
all of them give the same answer that
they just felt like coming to the
airport this is how i feel whenever i
wind up at mcdonald's they are let go
after 10 hours of interrogation but the
officials keep a close eye on them to
make sure they aren't hiding something
at breakfast the next morning jared
hears a specific tune playing in his
head no one else hears it which makes
him question his sanity following the
eventful morning he and grace bring cal
for chemo where they meet savvy upon
finding out she was also on 828 they're
shocked because cal is being treated
using her discovery meanwhile michaela
goes to work and finds lords they used
to be best friends but this time
michaela cannot get herself to talk to
her later she is told that she will have
to take a psyche val before she gets
back to work ben is crossing a signal
when he hears the same tune again and
decides to follow it this time he
reaches a street singer rad who is also
in the flight with them it turns out
that rad left his 13 year old son with
his neighbor when he first boarded the
plane now he has found out that his son
adio is in jail but no one is letting
the poor man meet him jared has been
called to help him which means he has to
help rad using the connections in the
nypd he arranges a meeting between rad
and his son adio has been arrested for
stealing from a jewelry store he works
in but he insists it wasn't him the guy
might be lying but something tells ben
that he is not at home ben tells
michaela to keep the callings a secret
from grace as well he doesn't want her
to feel like he is any different from
the ben he was five years ago especially
because she has been trying to keep her
distance when they are alone together
the next morning grace gets a call from
her boyfriend who is urging her to tell
ben the truth as she is explaining the
situation to him michaela hears her she
promises not to tell ben but asks grace
to quickly figure out what she wants to
do later michaela digs into adio's case
and finds out that all evidence points
towards him being the culprit since
there is no sign of forced entry and he
used a false id to get the job rad goes
to talk to him one more time but adio
insists it wasn't him he used the fake
id to get better jobs but he would never
steal something from the job he worked
so hard to get at night grace buys cal
new toys because his old ones were
donated however he misses things like
his rock collections and limited edition
legos it turns out that without grace's
knowledge olive had stored them in a
storage unit she and ben go to retrieve
this stuff and ben finds out the unit
belongs to grace's boyfriend danny olive
hugs him and apologizes before they can
move the boxes ben again hears the tune
but this time in real life he follows it
and finds out it is the ringtone of the
jewelry shop owner's son he is the one
who stole the jewelry and put the blame
on adio ben immediately calls the police
and gets him arrested in the end adio is
let free and rad couldn't be happier
mckayla goes through her facebook page
and finds several messages from lourdes
over the years it makes her remember the
friendship that they shared she goes to
lord's place and reunites with her
forgiving her for everything somewhere
else ben confronts grace about her love
affair he doesn't blame grace for being
with someone else to get over the pain
of losing her husband and child grace is
grateful to have such an understanding
man as her husband after that we are
introduced to kelly one of the 828
passengers who has been the most vocal
about what happened to them she goes on
interviews and blames the government for
hiding something then when she is
watching the news at night someone
shoots her dead in just a few hours her
house is surrounded by police ben also
finds out about it through the news and
asks the family to be careful of
strangers because the death might have
been related to her being a passenger he
gets a call from savvy who says that she
has found an undiscovered protein in
cow's blood that wasn't there before the
return they decide to keep it a secret
before she can do more research to find
out what exactly it is following the
call michaela and ben go to kelly's
house to investigate the murder however
they are interrupted by vance who kicks
them out because the matter related to
flight 828 is a matter of national
security outside they meet kelly's
husband taylor who says that his wife
had a calling yesterday before they ask
him more about it he walks away michaela
has also been hearing the phrase own
your truth repeatedly in her head she
hears kelly say the same thing in her
interview and realizes that she is meant
to find kelly's killer later she and ben
go to talk to taylor who is preparing
for the funeral he thinks that kelly was
killed because of the interviews and so
does the maid when they start to receive
guests the siblings see themselves out
however this reminds michaela of her
friend evie's death a few months before
the disappearance of the flight michaela
was in a car accident with evie evie
died in the crash and since michaela was
driving she never forgave herself to own
her truth she goes to evie's parents
home and finds her mother the last time
michaela was here she was kicked out
because the couple didn't want to see
her but this time beverly invites her in
michaela soon finds out that she has
dementia and still thinks her daughter
is alive her husband however still
blames michaela for evie's death after
the encounter michaela goes to work and
meets jared he did some digging on kelly
and found out that she and her husband
own a downtown mall michaela remembers
that the maid mentioned a mall while
talking about kelly yesterday that place
might hold the answers that they are
looking for subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching